[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
And welcome to episode 118
of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Melanie Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: Hi, Mark.
I'm here.
MARK MANDEL: You're here.
MELANIE WARRICK: That's
the important part.
MARK MANDEL: You're
not in SF, but you've
been a little under the
weather unfortunately.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
I have a little
under the weather.
MARK MANDEL: But I'm glad
to hear you're doing better.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: So this week we
have a really great episode
with Morgan McLean and
JBD from OpenCensus coming
to talk to us all about this
open source project which
is super, super exciting.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, definitely.
As always, we like to
kick off our podcast
with cool things of the week
and end with a question.
And this week's
question is, I heard
there are abilities to
natively extend Kubernetes.
What does that mean?
And also, how do I do that?
And you know, as
always, god only
knows where that question
might have come from.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe me.
It might have been from me.
MELANIE WARRICK: Maybe you.
Maybe you.
But maybe not.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe not.
MELANIE WARRICK: So to kick
off or cool things of the week,
for TensorFlow they're
already at release 1.6 which
is impressive considering I know
they just released 1.5 not too
long ago.
They also have their
Dev Summit coming up
at the end of this
month on March 30th.
And we'll provide a
link in the show notes.
And our colleagues,
Yufeng and Sara,
both came together and
did a video recently.
I know Yufeng's been doing
a number of videos on AI.
And they discussed how you
can do TensorFlow object
detection in IOS.
And they basically
build a custom
object detection mobile app.
And so we'll include
a link to that video.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Cool.
So this week I'm going to
plug one of my own things
which is kind of
cool and exciting.
I've been working with Ubisoft
and a bunch of Googlers as well
and a bunch of other
Ubisoft employees
to work on a open-source
dedicated game server hosting
open source project.
It's called Agones.
I will put a link to the
GitHub in the show notes
as well as the blog
post announcing it all.
But it is an open source project
for running dedicated game
servers for like real time
multiplayer games at scale
on top of Kubernetes.
So some of you may have seen
some of my blog posts talking
about doing that kind of stuff.
This is essentially
a productization
of that running as an
open source project.
So I'm pretty excited about it.
And we want a lot of
people to get involved.
So if this sounds
interesting to you,
please come join us on the
GitHub and the Google Group
and follow us on Twitter.
MELANIE WARRICK: You've been
working very hard on this.
This is definitely a
wonderful achievement.
MARK MANDEL: I'm pretty excited.
MELANIE WARRICK: You should be.
I can't wait to hear
when it's applied
to something, like what the
first game it gets applied to.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we're doing stuff.
We're doing stuff.
But yeah, lots of details
in the blog post for sure.
Thirdly, we have a blog post
by a fellow developer advocate
Colt McAnlis.
He has a bunch of really
nice tips and tricks
for optimizing performance
on Google Cloud Storage,
specifically around uploading
and downloading files.
He has a bunch of best
practices for, say,
like smaller files versus bigger
files, different command line
parameters you can try, all
sorts of interesting tips
and tricks.
There's one I
particularly like which
is avoiding the sequencing
naming bottleneck.
He talks actually about how
the namings of your files
can actually impact the
performance of uploading files
into Google Cloud Storage
and why that actually is.
So, yeah, if you
do a lot of stuff
with Google Cloud Storage, you
might want to check this out.
Because it's particularly
interesting to make sure
you can get the biggest
bang for your buck.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
And last but not
least, we also want
to mention that GCP has
a new interactive CLI.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
This is super cool.
I'm excited about this.
MELANIE WARRICK: It
actually really is.
The blog post itself
shows the CLI in action
and gives you a visual
understanding of what it looks
like.
Pretty neat because as you
type, it does auto complete.
And then it's also showing
definitions and information
on a screen below.
It's basically kind
of halfing the screen
and as you type you can see
what's going on below that.
It reminds me a little
bit of Jupiter Notebooks.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
I haven't played with
Jupiter Notebooks.
MELANIE WARRICK: I was going to
say, it's not exactly the same,
but it's similar.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
Now, what I like
about this is it
works for the G Cloud,
gsutil, the BigQuery utils, so
[INAUDIBLE] and kubectl.
And yeah, I'm actually really
excited to give this a shot.
So G Cloud alpha interactive
is the command to start it.
And really, I really
want to play with this.
This looks really cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah, I know.
I agree with you.
Anything that allows you to
use the CLI more effectively
makes me happy.
All right well, Mark.
I think it might be time for
us to go talk with our guests.
MARK MANDEL: Let's
go do that then.
Today I'm very happy to have two
people from the OpenCensus team
joining us today.
We have Morgan McLean,
did I get that right?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yes, you did.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Product manager for
OpenCensus, as well as
JBD, software engineer
joining us today.
How are you both doing?
JBD: Great.
How are you?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Doing well.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
Super happy to
have you both here.
I've been wanting to talk
about OpenCensus for ages.
Melanie can attest to that.
But before we get
stuck into that,
I'd love to hear more
about who you both are
and what you do at Google.
Morgan, why don't
we start with you?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Sure.
I've been at Google
for about two years.
I'm the product manager
for tracing, debugging,
and profiling.
This includes some
of our internal tools
as well as those under
the Stackdriver brand.
One of the biggest
things that I've
been PM-ing in
the last few years
is OpenCensus which is why
I'm here to talk to you about.
MARK MANDEL: JBD?
JBD: I'm an engineer
working on OpenCensus.
I'm actually pretty
new in this field.
But I have quite
significant background
in building developer
platforms and tools.
In the recent years
I was actually
focused on diagnostic tools of
the Go programming language.
And I kind of
switched to this area,
maybe became too
passionate too easily.
Because you know, there are tons
of potential and lots of gaps.
MARK MANDEL: And you
used to sit next to me.
But now you don't need anymore.
JBD: I'm sorry for that.
MELANIE WARRICK: You've escaped.
MARK MANDEL: So, this seems
like a good program manager
question, which is always fun.
But I'll be interested to hear
the difference in response.
At a high level, so
what is OpenCensus?
What is this project?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yes OpenCensus
is a single distribution
of language specific
libraries that
pull data, so instrumentation
and telemetry,
out of your application
so you can analyze
the app's performance later on.
So to start with, we're
focusing on distributive traces
and metrics.
So to put that even
more succinctly,
OpenCensus gives you
a really easy way
to pull traces and
metrics out of your app.
MELANIE WARRICK: Who would be
somebody that would use this?
MORGAN MCLEAN:
Primarily developers
of distributive services.
So OpenCensus stems from
a lot of our learnings
at Google, when
we wanted to build
distributed tracing,
distributed metrics in a big way
at high scale.
But really sort of the
benefits of OpenCensus
are applicable to
anybody building services
with some amount of scale.
MARK MANDEL: So you two terms
there-- metrics, tracing.
What are those things?
What's metrics?
What's tracing?
What do those two words mean?
MORGAN MCLEAN: So I
imagine a lot of listeners
the podcast are
familiar with metrics.
So traditionally
you'll pull things
like CPU consumption
or memory consumption
out of any of the nodes that
are hosting your application.
And that's, you know, a
fairly well solved problem.
OpenCensus focuses on
applicable metrics,
so pulling out things like
the number of requests
made to your application or
the latency of those requests,
as well as any other
metrics that you
want to build into
your code in a custom
way, which is a little
more difficult to pull out
these days.
The other term,
distributed tracing,
is probably one that people
are less familiar with.
So for those who don't
know, a distributed trace
lets you watch a single
request as it propagates
across all of your services.
So for example, if you have
an e-commerce application
and a customer comes in and
requests the cart service
to add an item to
their shopping cart,
you might get calls to
that shopping cart service
to then propagate down to maybe
a catalog service and others.
And a single distributed trace
shows you that entire chain
of requests that was based
off the single action made
by the customer.
And so it's really useful
for a couple reasons.
First, to determine how your
system operates if you're not
already familiar with it.
And that's at a
very basic level.
But additionally, each
hop along the way,
it shows you the latency.
And so when you want
to reduce the latency
of your application, which
becomes really important as it
grows, distributed tracing
is a great way to do that.
And finally, if you have an
error during that request,
the trace effectively works like
a really long and powerful call
stack.
So you can actually see
what happened that lead
to that error.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And my understanding
is that OpenCensus
is Cloud agnostic.
This is used for any kind
of distributed system.
Is that right?
JBD: Yeah.
Correct.
We are not dependent
on any Cloud
provider or metric collection
or tracing backend.
We collect data from your app
or your services or frameworks
in a vendor agnostic way.
And then export them
to specific backends.
So it can run anywhere and
against any of the supported
backends.
MARK MANDEL: What sort of
backends do you support?
JBD: Currently, the support
is dependent on the language
because lots of exporters
are a work in progress.
[INAUDIBLE] we support
to Zipkin, Stackdriver,
and [INAUDIBLE] for tracing,
Prometheus and Stackdriver
monitoring for
metric collection.
MELANIE WARRICK: Can you
also tell us a little more
about the work that you do?
JBD: Yeah.
I was actually about
to like it a little bit
of the question of
what do we do in terms
of like metric collection.
As Morgan mentioned that we
are a general purpose library.
So you can collect metrics
on the measures you define.
It could be related to
your business cases,
such as the number
of transactions
if you're a payment provider
or the number of videos
you have processed if you are
generating GIFs from videos.
But on top of that, we
have some canonical metrics
for protocols such as the
HTTP and RPC framework,
such as latency distribution,
or requests, or response size.
And I think that's where
OpenCensus is becoming more
powerful because all
these frameworks can
expose these canonical metrics.
And you just plug
them to your exporter
and get them out of the
box without doing much.
MARK MANDEL: It sounds
also like a good reason why
you'd want to use
something like OpenCensus
rather than just
pushing data straight
to something like
Stackdriver or Prometheus
or something like that.
It's giving you tools above and
beyond what the backends you
provide also give you.
JBD: They're, again, represented
in the backend somehow.
But it gives these
frameworks to actually
instrument without
depending on any vendor.
And it's very powerful.
No framework can be open ended
enough to say that I'm just
going to be using the Prometheus
instrumentation library
and this is the only exposition
format I will support.
Because we widely depend
on different backends.
And that's where
OpenCensus shines
because we're vendor agnostic.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So actually, JBD,
you're probably
a great person to ask for this.
As a developer, if I'm
sitting down and I'm like,
I want to use OpenCensus
with maybe and HTTP
or, I'm guessing, gRPC,
how does that look?
What does that
process look like?
JBD: Yeah.
We currently support
HTTP and gRPC both.
And we usually expect users
to start with our framework
integrations.
You pulled a library and you
pulled an integration actually
for Java, gRPC Java is coming
with OpenCensus integration
out of the box.
So you don't have to do any
additional thing in order
to turn it on.
And on top of that, you
enable some exporters
if you want to export
data to the backend.
We expect users to start with
this framework integrations.
And on top of that, if they have
any fine grained measurements,
depending on their technical
requirements or their business
cases, we expect them to
create custom traces or custom
measures and collect
more metrics.
But we expect people to depend
on the framework integrations.
It gives organizations
such an advantage
to deploy this widely all
across their stack very easily.
And it's like one of the key
things that we want to achieve.
OpenCensus or any
instrumentation layer
is just more useful
if you can deploy it
all across the stack
without much effort.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
You mentioned Java and Go.
Morgan, what languages
is supported?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah, so right
now we've really good support
across Java, Go and C++
for both tracing and stats.
And I believe we have tracing
support for Ruby, Python,
and PHP on top of that.
Eventually our goal, and we're
already working towards this,
is to get tracing and stat
support across Java, Go, C++,
.NET, Node Js, Ruby, Python,
PHP, and I'm missing one.
Which one am I missing?
JBD: Erlang, I'm guessing.
MORGAN MCLEAN:
Erlang, that's still--
I might still be missing
another one, but yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Since
this is an open project,
how can people contribute that
are not necessarily at Google?
Or how can people
contribute in general?
JBD: It's very straightforward.
You to our GitHub
organization, pick the language
implementation you want.
So we actually have two big--
we have language
implementations.
But on top of that, we
also have a specs repo
where we discuss the concepts
and the overall design issues.
If you want to contribute to the
design issues and the concepts,
you go to the specs repo,
either start an issue
or start a pull request if
it's a trivial change that
can be handled in the scope
of PR and contribute that way.
If you want to contribute to
the language implementations,
you need to go to the
language implementation repo.
And again, we have
contributing docs.
So you just follow the
steps and contribute.
MELANIE WARRICK: Similar to most
open source projects basically.
JBD: Yeah, exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
It also sounds like
at Google or at least
coming out of Google
in some other ways
we've got a lot of
projects that seem to be
doing related sort of things.
I'm thinking like we
were talking about gRPC
just a little bit ago.
Istio seems to come
to mind as well.
Is there overlap there?
I mean, you said you
support the gRPC,
but is there overlap from
gRPC or Istio with OpenCensus
or like hooks or anything
special going on there?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
It's kind of
interesting, because just
to give you a bit of
history, like OpenCensus
is an open source version of
something called Census which
is our instrumentation framework
that we use inside of Google.
And in many ways, gRPC and Envoy
are equivalents of the systems
that Census inside
of Google hooks into.
And so interestingly,
with these other projects
being open source
at the same time,
we have a big opportunity
to integrate with them,
to give external developers
the same experience
we have inside of Google for
basically automatic tracing
on all requests that
propagate through our network.
And so to answer your question
a little more succinctly
then, yes.
So we've already built
automatic integration for gRPC.
We're building automatic
integration for Envoy
right now.
And so Envoy, of course, is the
application side car component
of the Istio project.
And then for the
Istio Mixer, which
is another part of
the Istio project,
we have some designs
that we'll start
working on shortly
for doing things
like tracing aggregation.
So you can capture traces
and configure your backend
a little more efficiently.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Morgan, you were talking
a little bit about the history.
But did it go from being
Census to OpenCensus?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
It's actually a
really good question.
We have a blog post
coming out on this soon.
So there were a couple
of factors at play.
For one, the census
team had simply
been wanting to open source
their work for quite some time.
And Google has a long history
of open sourcing projects
even when there's no sort of
ulterior motivate to doing it,
just because teams
inside are encouraged
to do that and make things
available to the community.
Next, on Stackdriver
trace, we were
developing our own
instrumentation libraries.
So this effort in
the long run is going
to be replaced with OpenCensus.
And the cost of developing
these libraries,
as any vendor in the industry
can attest to, is rather high.
And on top of that, the cost
of maintaining these libraries,
because you have to have these
integrations into various web
frameworks across so
many languages, just
continues to be high.
And so you have these
very large teams
who are just ensuring that
your tracing system can work
with framework x on language y.
And so we were hoping to
find a more creative solution
to addressing that, both
for us and our competitors.
And then finally,
at Google, there
was a need particularly
on the storage teams,
to get more instrumentation
into Cloud client libraries, so
particularly services like
Big Table and Spanner.
Customers do sometimes have
performance challenges.
And we need a quicker
way of determining
if that's due to something
happening on the customer's
end, maybe they are
calling an API in a way
that we don't'
really recommended,
a way it's not designed for.
Or maybe there's legitimately
a problem on the service.
And those teams in the past
have lacked a lot of insight
into that.
So resolving some customer
performance issues
would take days, or
even just more hours
than they would want.
And so, getting a way for them
to get both trace requests
going through from their
library storage services
and also just ensure that they
can give more instrumentation
to customers, regardless of
whatever tracing or metrics
backend that they're using.
So not just Stackdriver.
And so really, the decision
to release and so heavily fund
the OpenCensus project
was due to a combination
of these factors.
And it was sort of
this perfect storm
of wanting to open
source things,
that our own tracing product
needed better instrumentation,
and then teams at Google
wanted their customers
to gain much more insight
into their client libraries.
And it worked out really well.
MELANIE WARRICK:
I could definitely
see the value of having
that holistic picture
and being able to sort of
move from being specifically
affiliated to a certain
product or service
because that way you can drive
after that holistic tracing.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
It would be a much more
challenging conversation,
with our partners in particular,
if we just went to them
and we're like, yeah,
this is the library's
recruited for our own
Stackdriver tracing products.
You should use them too.
A lot of partners wouldn't
take that seriously,
for very good reasons.
And they would be
somewhat suspicious of it.
But it's interesting,
when we meet
with other vendors, particularly
other vendors in this space who
are also Cloud vendors
like ourselves or at least
own large, well used APIs, they
have the exact same challenges.
And so it becomes a very
straightforward conversation
because we say, hey you can
embed this in your client
libraries as well.
And it turns out--
I suspect, I don't
know this for certain--
but I suspect that the
other Cloud vendors,
they also want this
to work when people
are using third party tracing
applications, not just
their own.
And so the fact that
this is an open project
and it's going to be gaining a
lot more partners in the future
is very appealing.
JBD: As a maintainer of some
of these client libraries,
we finally realized that there
is no point of having no vendor
agnostic solution.
And I think within the Go
programming language scope,
we were actually
thinking about maybe
we should have some
tracing and some sort
of like instrumentation
library, not
just tracing but metrics
in the standard library.
But it became quite a clear
case that this is not just
like one language.
Any organization you go,
they depend on three or four
languages.
So you need to be
able to provide this
all across different languages.
And then I saw the actual,
clear benefit of OpenCensus
and just decided to join this
project rather than doing
things in my own corner.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
I mean, it sounds actually like
that the whole vision of it
sounds amazing.
And in theory, if
I set OpenCensus
inside my application, I
could have metrics and tracing
that goes all the way through
from my custom application
code all the way
through to the SDKs
that I use to integrate
with the Cloud that I'm on.
And then potentially other
Clouds or other places
around, assuming they also--
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yep.
Or other APIs that
you're calling.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That
sounds kind of awesome.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yeah, really it does.
JBD: And there's also an
additional [INAUDIBLE] format
standardization effort.
So lots of vendors want
to also standardize
how we propagate the
trace IDs around.
So if a trace has, for
example, been started somewhere
in AWS X-Ray, we will be able
to understand it and like
keep adding more to
that trace and so on.
So there's a big effort
all across other vendors
to finally create this agnostic
view so we can actually
gather the instrumentation
data and utilize it.
MELANIE WARRICK: What
additional feature
enhancements or connections
are you working on?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
We've got a couple of things.
And we looked sort
of longer term,
sort of through the end
of 2018 for OpenCensus.
One is something
that we've called,
it's got several
different names,
but it's sort of retroactive
tracing or delayed sampling.
But effectively, it's
making a decision
on whether you want to trace a
request, not at the beginning,
so not when the request
comes in and hits your load
balancer or your very first
service, but later on.
And what this would
enable is selectively
sampling requests that
had errors, for example,
or requests that
have higher latency.
This is not a trivial
things to achieve.
But we think we can do it.
And we want to add it to
OpenCensus for all vendors
to take advantage of.
If I look more at sort of
the breadth for OpenCensus,
there's a couple sort of big
rocks that we want to focus on.
The biggest would
be errors and logs.
And so we haven't put a ton
of thought into this yet.
But one of the
biggest advantages
that we see in our telemetry
systems internally inside
of Google is being able to
link traces to logs or traces
to other signals,
basically being
able to take the
context of a request
where something happened
and include that
on any other signals
associated with that request.
And we've also seen that being
very effective with Stackdriver
trace, our customers
on Google App
Engine who get this built in.
And it's sort of annoyingly
hard to pull this off today
when you have like separate
tracing and logging and error
reporting and profiling
and other libraries.
Because most of them
don't look for each other.
You might be using libraries
from different vendors.
But if we bring this
in through OpenCensus
and it actually starts
gaining traction,
and achieves some
amount of popularity,
everyone can
benefit, even vendors
who only offer a single
feature like maybe
logging or only tracing can
benefit from that correlation
signals.
And their customers
can benefit from being
able to go from a trace
that might be in Zipkin
and tie that in to some
metrics that are in Prometheus
or log stored somewhere else.
And that's really like one of
the big, big things that we
want to drive long
term with Open Census
is that correlation
between signals.
MARK MANDEL: That was
going to lead into question
I was thinking about
as you were saying it,
which is you do both
tracing and metrics.
Like why do you put those
two things together?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Part of
it's just that those
are sort of two areas
in the market where
we saw a need for some amount
of-- perhaps standardization
is the wrong word, but some
amount of convergence, where
the market for a long time
hadn't been that well-served
by projects that did that.
But additionally, it's that
our visions are much grander.
Tracing and metrics
is just a start.
We eventually want to
bring in logs, errors,
profiling software, any other
signals that we can bring in
JBD: I want to say that
OpenCensus is a cross tech
instrumentation framework.
What we mean by cross
tech is we actually
propagate some dimensions.
We call them tags.
So you can have multiple
different perspectives
to take a look at your
instrumentation data.
And these tags are
arbitrary things.
For example, you can ask
questions like, give me
all the metrics
come in, originated
at this particular service.
Or give me all the metrics
that has been originated
by this specific customer.
So the goal is actually have
the tag propagation in place.
And then multiple other signal
types can benefit from that.
MARK MANDEL: Have you had
like a really good response
from the community?
JBD: I think people are
generally extremely interested
because the gap is very clear.
For most frameworks
and library authors,
there's absolutely
no way to instrument.
And they can clearly
see that this project
is filling that gap.
So the response has
been very positive
because we are addressing that.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Good to have that
positive response already.
And you said it was very new
so it was in the last month
that this was
actually announced?
JBD: Yeah, we announced
it, I think, last month.
It's been almost a month
or a couple of weeks.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah.
It was a fairly
quiet announcement
at the Google Open Source Blog.
We're having basically
like a rolling launch where
we're making more
and more noise,
we're going to more
and more conferences,
and we're making
blog posts, and just
sort of trying to ramp
up the level of attention
that the project gets.
MARK MANDEL: And JBD, you did
a talk at KubeCon, didn't you?
JBD: We did actually.
We did it together.
That was the first talk we
gave about this project.
And I followed up
with other talks.
I think there's a
lot of work in order
to explain the concepts we have,
why we solve the things the way
we do before giving
them maybe the solution.
So we're thinking about also
spending some time educating
about this concept.
And our library
implementations are still
kind of like work in progress.
And we sometimes break APIs.
So we want to be in a
very stable situation
before we start widely
talking about this project
and recommending it
for the general use.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Is there anything
else that you would
want to plug around actual
talks or other efforts
or community involvement
that's coming up?
JBD: We have a bunch
of talks coming up.
Morgan has a Velocity
Conf talk in June.
MORGAN MCLEAN: I think
we've got Velocity.
We've also made
applications for,
and of course we don't we
haven't heard back yet,
but I'm pretty confident
we'll get into most of these,
at KubeCon, SRE Con,
Monitorama, and additionally
some of the Google-specific
conferences like GCP
Next and Google I/O.
MARK MANDEL: Basically wherever
good presentations are found.
MORGAN MCLEAN: I
mean, yeah, we're
trying to cast a wide net.
I'm sure there are conferences
that we should be at maybe
haven't applied to.
But we're trying to go as
many as we feasibly can.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And if people are keen to
either get involved or start
playing with OpenCensus,
where should they go?
JBD: They should to
go on opencensus.io
and take a look at our
GitHub organization.
I will put the
links to your doc.
So check out our specs and
language implementations
and give it a try.
We have enough guidelines
about getting started
and you can just try to use
it and give us feedback.
That will be very
appreciated at this stage.
MARK MANDEL: And I'm seeing
here as well, there's
a 2018 Google Summer of Code.
JBD: That is also true.
We have several ideas.
So if you're interested,
take a look at the list.
Contact us.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Should they also
send you examples of
how they're using it
and things that they're
finding with it?
JBD: Oh, yeah.
That would be awesome.
We've actually seen a
bunch of blog posts already
from several users.
So it would be totally
so nice if you can write
any guidelines or any tips.
If you can write
conceptual documentation,
that will also be nice.
I'm also trying
to spend some time
this week just to write more
documentation for the website.
We will have like soon more
conceptual docs and so on.
But any help would be
highly appreciated.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, we really appreciate you
both taking your time to come
and talk to us and share
what OpenCensus is.
Is there anything that you
still wanted to mention
before we close this out?
MORGAN MCLEAN: Not on my end.
JBD: Contribute.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah,
please contribute.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Please contribute.
All right, well thank you again.
And thank you, Mark, for
getting this together for us.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thank
you so much for joining us.
We really appreciate
you taking the time.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Yeah,
thanks for having us.
JBD: Thank you so much.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank
you again, Morgan and JBD.
It was great to talk to
you about OpenCensus.
It's always great to hear
about what kind of open source
projects that are going on and
how they're being supported.
So Mark, I think
now it's time to ask
you the question of the week.
I heard that there are abilities
to natively extend Kubernetes.
What does that mean?
And also, how do I do that?
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
So yeah, I can now
talk more openly
about Agones and the work
I've been doing in that space.
I have a whole
bunch of questions
of the week around Kubernetes,
which are really nice.
MELANIE WARRICK:
It's very helpful.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I want to give the
short answer here
but I'm going to put a lot of
resources in the show notes
because there's a
bunch of stuff around.
And some of this can be a
little bit hard to find.
But it's something I
want to talk about.
So, yeah, so what does it mean
to natively extend Kubernetes.
Essentially this means that
Kubernetes has the ability
to essentially add endpoints
to the underlying API which
then propagates out.
So if you want to add your
own nouns to Kubernetes,
for example, so you know how
we have deployments and pods
and things like that.
Kubernetes has these things
called custom resource
definitions which you
can configure and install
through YAML files of the
API to add your own nouns.
So if you want to add an
Acme or a Foo or a widget
or whatever that thing
is that you can then
store configuration
information against,
you can do that
inside Kubernetes.
I'm going to add
some more links.
But you can do that through
custom resource definitions.
And the second part
is a set of things
that probably either heard
of either controllers
or operators.
I tend to use the term
controllers just because that's
the one I prefer.
But those are the things that
are custom pieces of code
you can put inside Kubernetes
to react to when custom resource
definitions, or other things,
really anything, happens
inside Kubernetes.
So you may have seen there's
like a [? Memcached ?]
operator.
I've seen [INAUDIBLE] operators.
I've seen a bunch of
different ones around there.
Agones itself has custom
resource definitions
for game servers and
a controller for that.
But that combination
combined means
that suddenly you can install
this stuff into Kubernetes,
I can then go kubectl, get
game server, for example,
with the Agones and it shows
up natively inside Kubernetes.
I even got code completion
too, which is cool.
If I look at the
API points, I can
see that extra stuff
has been added.
All that stuff is native
inside Kubernetes.
Like you can take
advantage of security.
It's all really,
really cool stuff.
Stuff I'm really excited about.
But with those two things,
those are the two key words
that you're looking for there.
But I'm going to put a bunch
of stuff in the show notes
with some video resources,
links to articles,
all the different Go libraries
that usually you can use
for all this kind of stuff too.
So if this is stuff that
you're interested in,
you'll have a nice
little resource there.
MELANIE WARRICK: Great.
Well, I think that about
does it for this week.
Mark, is there
anywhere where people
are going to be able to
find you in the near future?
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So I can talk now
about all the things
I'm doing at GDC because
Agones is out, which is lovely.
Yeah, so at GDC,
I'll be at the booth.
I'm doing a half hour
talk at the booth.
We'll put links to
where that is and when
that is in the show notes.
It's on Wednesday.
I can't remember the
exact time, unfortunately.
I'll be talking at the
booth about Agones.
We'll be doing a
sponsored talk as well.
Same thing where
we're doing a What's
New in Firebase
and Google Cloud.
So I'll be talking about that.
We're also sponsoring the Women
in Games International Party.
So I'll just be
there hanging out.
We're doing media
expert sessions.
I think that's probably about
it But I'll be all around GDC.
If anyone wants to
find me, just hit me up
on Twitter or email or LinkedIn.
MELANIE WARRICK: And
that's all next week?
MARK MANDEL: That's
all next week, yes.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Are you so excited?
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Part of me is really--
because I love GDC.
Part of me is very
excited for it
because there's
so much going on.
Part of me is almost really
happy for it to be over.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Well, we'll talk
about what you're going to
do to relax once you're done.
But I'm glad your big
week is ahead of you.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Are you going anywhere
or doing anything?
MELANIE WARRICK: No.
I'm going to rest.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Take care of yourself.
MELANIE WARRICK: I will.
All right.
Well, I think that does
it for us for this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, Melanie.
Thank you for joining me for yet
another episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thanks
to everyone for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]